[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today Nick
starts us off in Salt Lake City Nick
welcome to the
show hey um so yeah I I've had a pretty
big life change recently as far as
income goes uh about a year ago I was
making $2,000 a month working at a steel
plant and then my brother-in-law told me
that he thought I could sell and it
turns out I could and my income has now
since quintupled I don't know it would
take me five years to do what I I mean
it's it's an insane jump and my wife and
I are trying to manage it and I feel
like we're hemorrhaging and we haven't
saved enough considering how much we've
made congratulations congrats so what
are we talking are we talking 10K a
month closer to 20 whoa congrats is that
your take-home pay my boss thinks uh for
tax I'm not sure what my that's the
other thing I got to figure out taxes in
this too and so I just oh they're not
taking taxes out nope nope I'm
technically a self-employed
1099 okay so you better be putting away
30% of that every single month in a
savings account I've putting away so we
save so we have between our taxes and
then our church donation we put side
about 45% okay and then we live off of
about well our budget puts us at 10% but
I feel like we're not doing that is what
we're living off of and then we try to
save the other 45 but that's not what's
been happening how how long has this
been going
on about six months okay cut yourself a
whole bunch of
slack okay yeah like you this is this
rare erir congratulations y'all had a
fun run and now you got to go be adults
and it's all good okay yeah don't live
in the a Shucks a because what you are
experiencing is the upside of sales what
you haven't experienced is when our
congressmen decide to throw tennis balls
at each other just for fun and shoot
each other with Nerf guns and shut
everything down the other side of sales
right you're like a farmer now and you
farm make no money no money no money
then crops and then no money right so
that's awesome you just got to plan for
the future so six months youall had a
wild time good times and now we got to
be grown-ups right yeah okay so give us
a picture of your financial situation do
you guys have any debt do you have money
in savings so we have a little the only
debt we've brought on was on the advice
of our accountant to try and bring our
tax Li our tax liability down um we
bought my wife a new car um before that
she had a little car that we had paid
off and I have a truck that I have paid
off your accountant told you to go get a
car
loan he told us to get a loan so we
could not necessarily a loan but to buy
a car so we could use it as a ride off
oh my
gosh dude is Michael Scott your
accountant like how did you think this
was a good idea that was it's what I've
had a lot of people around me that they
said that's what they did and so that's
what we kind of thought we should do you
need different necessarily but yeah okay
what's the car
loan um it is 32,000 okay the good news
is you have an amazing income and you
can pay this thing off really fast and
it's now not too big of a portion of
your world 60 days you were making two
grand a month I would be like sell this
car today 60
days yeah 60 got it okay so
you have you have to make very focused
goals with your money right now you're
in baby step two you have a th000 bucks
in the bank I assume you have a lot more
than that in the bank right now 15 of
the bank 15 of the bank so this car loan
can already get cut in half today and
then with the next few paycheck well
yeah the bank I guess if you include I I
won't talk about the tax account but
yeah 15 and savings yeah tax account
doesn't that's that is Untouchable we
don't touch it don't touch it don't
touch it it does not exist yes until tax
time and they go hey you owe $660,000 in
taxes and instead of going oh my gosh
you went okay yeah we save for that
great yeah so we're GNA pay off this car
as soon as possible then we're going to
Stack Up 3 to six months of expenses in
an emergency fund that we also don't
touch unless there's a true
emergency yeah and that's what that's
what this money is for because we live
off of about including the car about
2500 a month because our rent is only
$800 great so this will help accelerate
you to Baby Steps 456 now are you in a
home you said you're renting you want to
buy a home one day we want to buy a home
next year right now the situation we're
in we got um we got fortunate I suppose
um our my wife's grandparents have a
house that they it's a 42 that they rent
us and so we're in a pretty good near
Salt Lake
City no well we're close to Salt Lake
okay Nick you all are winning life right
now you falling through the a glitch in
The Matrix man this is your chance to
get a
hit I yeah I mean it's just I I mean I
just learned I have a talent in sales I
mean I've broken every record this
company had and it just was it's a lot
to handle but also but six months you
can have a lot of talent or you could
have just gotten real
lucky yeah there's that too I don't know
that's the thing right both so it's
probably a little bit of both and so
um George tell me if I'm I'm crazy here
I almost sense a need for you guys you
and your wife
to roll back for M maybe just say we're
going to do a 90-day Sprint but roll
back some of the gazelle
intensity remember what it felt like to
be broke and get that laser
focused yeah because if you don't you're
going to wake up in a
mess yeah you're gonna buy a house that
you can't afford you buy a house based
on 20,000 bucks a month and then the
Builder's going to be like what are you
doing you're going to your income's
going to keep going up and you're going
to buy a house based off $330,000 a
month and someone's going to tell you
you got to get a car to write off too
and you're going to get a BMW and next
thing you know you're gonna be Dave Rams
you be
broke yeah so here's the deal you got to
keep living like you make $22,000 a
month for the next six months until
you're out of this hole you're in a
great place you have a financial
Foundation you're investing 15% you're
saving money towards that down payment
cuz you have like a fake life right now
paying 800 bucks a month in rent making
$20,000 a month utilize this while you
can instead of the YOLO Vibes that
you've been putting out and you will be
in such a great place financially six
months from now me and George tried to
convince people for three years the
government is not charging you any
interest on your student loans this is
there's never been a better time in
human history to pay them off than right
this second your payments are on sale
and 1% I have zero student debt I know
but I'm saying 1% of America took our
advice oh yeah the other 99 are right
now going oh God what are we going to do
similar to you if you for 6 months
pretend that y'all are broke and you get
an ENT an emergency fund you pay off
this a car get a new accountant go to
ramsy solutions.com tax get a new
accountant god sakes um fire Michael
Scott but you do this for six months you
owe nobody anything you have six months
emergency fund built up and youall
starting a house fund brother your whole
world is different and so is your
marriage everything is different
congratulations man never do it for the
write off that's just life advice for
you America this is the ramsy show